[Music]
Google opens a new cloud region in the
Netherlands what does that mean and why
are we so proud of that
I'm Matt feigl and when I'm not working
on the Google wind project to guarantee
sunny skies my team helps companies in
the Netherlands learn how to use Google
cloud let's start with the question of
what a region means in the first place
with this opening Google cloud platform
products are now offered and hosted from
the Netherlands that makes us the 14th
Google cloud region in the world so here
on the spot where Google's transatlantic
cable enters Europe we now have a
state-of-the-art data center that houses
our Google cloud platform products the
great thing is our Netherlands data
center is one of the largest and most
efficient data centers in the world
everything you need to set up your cloud
and make it scalable you will find here
from compute to big data storage and
networking we are especially proud of
this location because it is all about
green energy together with an ACO we
have invested in a wind farm that
supplies the energy for this data center
making it completely co2 neutral for our
customers this means better performance
lower latency and more flexibility you
can choose to allocate your applications
or storage environment in one place or
spread them over multiple locations in
the Netherlands we have so many great
local customers like Bolcom no personal
message bird we're online blend 'el and
Philips you to name a few take philips
Lighting for example it's incredibly
important that the hue Pat form works as
quickly as possible
if you switch your light on or off video
it's important that your light responds
right away because Phillip lighting runs
the entire back-end on our cloud
platform the users see great performance
even if the signal goes all the way back
to your lamp via satellite
for me the most important reason to open
a region in the Netherlands is because
we are here for the long term here at
Google we are serious about the cloud
business and now we are your new
neighbor
right here right next door consider this
an invitation feel free to reach out or
even visit us about how we can help you
to use Google cloud talk to you soon
[Music]